what if anime was real oh my God I just
wish it was true shut the [ __ ] up it's
rare nowadays that I ever go back to
revisit an anime do you see how many
shows are airing every season for this
day and age I can barely keep up with
what's coming out you think I've got
time to go back and watch [ __ ] like the
heroes overpowered but overly cautious
huh who's still watching this who still
thinks about this we're all consuming so
much media now that even if you enjoyed
a show Even if you found something good
in the moment you can't always predict
when something will actually stick with
you because we move on so fast but there
is a show that's been living right
through my mind and refuses to leave
even years after it's aired now a show
so unique so batshit insane it explored
a premise I've never seen an anime
before and since a show that seemingly
everyone around me has already stopped
talking about and moved on from so
wanting to know why I couldn't do the
same I tried seeing if it was actually
as good as I thought it was and
deserving to stick on in my memory and
upon my rare second viewing I realized I
I was wrong
it was so much better
[Music]
but I'm getting ahead of myself because
first it's sponsor time this video is
brought to you by neuro Cloud neuro
cloud is a brand new up-and-coming
roguelike strategy game spin-off of
girls Frontline sets after an accident
occurs in a virtual world the bionic
autonomous dolls that's wife used to you
and I are scattered all over the cloud
and you the professor must gather them
and seek resources to survive and search
out a way to return to the real world
that's right it's an esecai sci-fi baby
the game's roguelike gameplay is
streamlined for a more casual player
experience striking the perfect balance
of strategy and fun navigate your way
through fully non-linear branching paths
and challenge randomly generated maps
with unlimited possibilities every time
you clear a level you'll get function
cards and you can use them to improve
your team and find the perfect strategy
to clear the next level now tell me that
but every character has an ultimate move
as well each one complete with a fully
unique Nirvana specific animation
sequence and mag just look at this I was
beyond impressed by every single one I
use there's nothing more satisfying than
dropping you out and watching this play
out as you clear the room of enemies it
also helps out the girls themselves look
absolutely incredible the game's unique
sci-fi art style really Embraces the
setting and provides you with the
character Arc featuring detailed
backgrounds that really gives you a
sense of each doll's personality they
aren't just pngs you can use these
things as your bloody desktop wallpaper
guys they are just pngs so what are you
waiting for follow the link in the
description to download the game and
start your adventure today also make
sure to use the gift code on screen to
get yourself some free exclusive
benefits thank you very much to
neurocloud for sponsoring me today back
to the video
what would the world be like if fiction
became reality
this is a question Sota unexpectedly has
to deal with when one day he gets
transported right into an anime that
he's watching but wait wait hold on hold
on he gets transported back and finds
out that the anime characters have come
with him suddenly characters from all
sorts of anime games manga genres start
appearing in the real world and start
duking it out it's an all-out brawl the
fantasy night starts flying around in
our reality this made someone's day of
Babylon except it's got bloody Rocky
launchers [ __ ] magical girl appears
how cool is this concept now I know what
you're thinking oh Google talking about
another isekai yes
but actually no look yes we can keep up
the meme and call this an easy card but
the premise and appeal is not even in
the same galaxy as your standard easy
guys so no I don't like this because
it's an Easter guy
I like it because it's fake one thing I
absolutely love in any medium is seeing
elements that don't traditionally exist
together clash with each other in a
story like that was the biggest reason I
initially started to get invested in the
MCU in the first place growing up I was
never massive into superhero movies I
won phase one first release that's
mostly how I felt then Avengers came out
and I was like wait I get to see a
billionaire engineer fight a Nordic God
and a super soldier in the mix now you
have my attention Hulk starts wrecking
[ __ ] aliens blow up New York and
Hawkeyes like guys so I have a bow and
arrow then slowly you start seeing the
world changing governments have to
acknowledge the threat of alien
invasions space travel gets introduced
as a normal thing Doctor Strange comes
out great I guess we have wizards now
too black panther okay now there's a
secret Advanced civilization Thanos in
bays and Hawkeye still like gozos bow
and arrow Thanos you you better you
better watch out I'm gonna gonna shoot
you with a sorrow it's a it's a really
really sharp arrow pew pew magic space
technology Gods super soldiers you have
all these elements all coexisting all
coming to head in the same universe not
as a gimmick but building off each other
for a grander plot and this is the basis
of why I love recreator so much this is
what happens when you take every cliche
genre in anime and crash them into each
other take a look at this scene we start
off with the magical girl and definitely
not saber arguing ethics with the
equivalent of a scheming yandere isaia
from that's going about as well as you
imagined then Superior Arsenal and a
final fantasy Mage jump in negotiations
have broken down not saber uses her
Noble Phantasm it starts wrecking [ __ ]
her and Superior Arsenal go at it
suddenly a Guilty Gear character
casually walks in he doesn't have magic
he's got a [ __ ] gun I started
blasting magic vs guns what wins go what
beats guns JoJo stands a Persona
character with a JoJo stand joins The
Fray in battles by sucking sorry I mean
using his stand seeing all this violence
the magical girl just wants everyone to
get along and decides to join him to try
and stop the fighting with the power of
friendship and more violence it's
karnish it's Mayhem and just as you
think you can't get any crazy a giant
Mech just drops in and
you have a fake character fighting a
Fantasy character fighting your Guilty
Gear character fighting a Persona
character fighting a magical girl and in
the middle of this there's just a
monogatouille villain causing complete
chaos chaos seeing Havoc like this
unfolded some of the most fun I've ever
had as an anime fan because if you're a
weeb who's watched shows with the
characters like this in them how the
hell does this not put a smile in your
face this is a show that rewards those
who are familiar with the tropes of
anime by taking the cliches you know and
flipping them into unfamiliar territory
so you may be wondering why the hell did
everyone else forget about this show
that's what I want to [ __ ] know the
most common complaint I see about this
show is that it's just bogged down with
too much dialogue because oh Lord
there's a lot of it the first two
episodes open up with a bang you've got
giant robots you got explosions got this
badass girl playing a gun with a sword
like a violin to control other swords
and you're like oh God I'm so ready this
is gonna be awesome then the next few
episodes hits and it's like
can we get back to the sword lady
again please the first time I watched
this I came in with the expectations
that this was just gonna be a dumb fun
action romp with anime from every genre
so when there were several episodes
stints of nothing we're just talking I
would honestly just half zone out
waiting for the next action scene but on
my second viewing because I knew when
the action was coming because I wasn't
just anticipating the next big fight
scene I had the chance to actually fully
immerse myself to what they were talking
about and I thought damn
this is actually interesting as hell
recreators doesn't just settle with
presenting this wacky concept of hey
guys what if anime was real but serious
thoughts to what struggles would
actually exist if characters of fiction
could break the barrier to our world
from the biggest effects to the smallest
details characters that get transported
here end up having some sort of sensory
overload when they come to our world the
air feels different the food tastes more
flavorful colors are brighter what they
experience in their world is only
dependent on how much detail their
author puts into their work how
descriptive was the orange juice they
drank did the author deem it necessary
to add coffee to their World building
but here taste smells sight a whole
world of Sensations they've never
experiences now at their fingertips and
I just thought this was a cool little
detail I never would have thought about
but on top of this recreaters Builds on
its concept to explore so many
interesting ideas like what if these
creations could actually meet their
creators we've seen this before with
gimmicky fourth wall breaks but two
fictional characters meeting your author
is essentially meeting your God the
person responds for for all the bad
things all the natural disasters all
fortnite dances to ever exist how would
that make you feel would you be happy in
awe angry knowing they allowed Sasuke to
do this how would you feel if your God
didn't even care about their own story
and only did it for money how would you
feel if your God was a pervert and you
were only created as an object of sexual
desire how would you feel if you met
your Gods only to find out they were a
devil knowing that you were a character
in a tragedy seeing these creations cope
with the fact that their God was not a
God but in fact so disappointingly
mortal and their entire lives were just
stories played out for entertainment was
an aspect that added so many fascinating
angles every creation shares a different
Dynamic with their creator some came to
resent their creators some formed a
pseudo-parent child Bond some just chose
to ignore it and take a deep puff of
some of that good copium and this took
the archetypes these characters were
based on and so many interesting
directions take mamika the magical girl
right in episode 2 we find out magical
girls are packing some heat her family
friendly magic starts [ __ ] [ __ ] up
buildings are erupting they're her
explosions everywhere she almost kills a
guy people are [ __ ] then afterwards
she looks around and is like oh my God
who did this you did this you caused all
this collateral damage
what the [ __ ] is collateral damage she
comes from a children's show where there
is no violence and every problem is
solved by the power of friendship so
when she finds out she can cause serious
harm and not all conflicts can be solved
by telling people to get along she's
just like
this is a character that's completely
out of her depth but through these
interactions she starts to learn a new
world view she changes her perspective
changes her approach realizes the world
is more complicated than it is in a
children's cartoon and eventually starts
taking actions in the way her original
archetype never would have while still
remaining the same core character of
wanting to save the people around her
this is something that Rings true for
every creation we see in the show
alisteria a righteous fantasy Knight
understanding a world where Justice
isn't just Black or White Blitz a
character who has to come to terms that
he was created for the sole purpose of
suffering Celestia Kania yuya margane
character archetypes we recognize the
force into situations we would never
usually see them in and because of that
they can slowly change into far more
interesting characters than they ever
would have got the chance to in their
original stories it's [ __ ] like this
that had me hooked the entire run where
most shows would take this premise and
go anime characters in real life
recreator sits down and goes okay what
if that one person was like this or that
character was like that how would they
react how does that change to the
dynamic and that spawns another idea
then another the show is bursting with
so many unique Concepts that takes
advantage of its insane premise the
action can be high obtained turbo Fisto
fun but at the same time it's a series
that's not afraid to just sit down and
spend some time chilling with the
characters just struggling to live in
the world does this make up for all the
excessive dialogue no even with all this
interesting stuff there's so much of
what I like to call anime bullshittery
characters will just pull a five minute
Exposition dump and why other people are
being transported to the real world how
do we fix this why the world is coming
to a [ __ ] end and I hate to do this
but girl this is kind of on you half the
time when the plot doesn't know where to
go our lovely Mage Meteora will suddenly
get a bright idea and be like guys I
have a theory go on
that is a fascinating Theory do you have
any sources my sources that I made it
the [ __ ] up the show spends so much time
and makes up so much [ __ ] trying to
explain its own mechanics and while some
of it is cool a lot of it's really
really really did not need to be that
complicated recreaters looking at you
nobody gives a rat's ass of your PhD
level of [ __ ] you used to explain
why anime characters are here and why
the world is coming to an end if you
needed to add Stakes you have an Opie
villain who hates the world just give a
time limit before her power becomes
fully active or some [ __ ] come on look
we're not here for this
[Music]
we're here for this
foreign
[Music]
things as well like manganese power
makes no sense and it's just broken in
every way the final conclusion takes so
much suspension of disbelief and it's
just Anime [ __ ] where he shot up
into the [ __ ] Stratosphere but
honestly I don't really mind the more
time passes The more I've just
appreciated what this series tried to do
and watching it again made me rethink
some of the things I thought I hated
about it I remember the first time I
watched this I absolutely despised Sota
Soto is a shriveled scrotum of a
protagonist early on we find out that he
knows the origin of the villain
everyone's trying to find out about and
he just does nothing doesn't tell anyone
doesn't do anything the plot goes on
standstill just for him and I remember
the first time I watched this I was
fuming livid that this Shinji ass
[ __ ] was taking up valuable
screens on when I could be watching a
giant robot turbo fist the [ __ ]
flying Knight but then you find out the
reason for it and I was like oh
I think I get it now Sota isn't a hero
like the characters he's standing next
to he's just a normal dude who likes
anime shy socially awkward living with
his own trauma afraid to face the
problems in his life head on
frustratingly afraid to take action but
frustratingly real he's someone who
needs the heroes you see in anime to
give him something to Aspire to be and
that's when I realized that recreaters
is a story about stories why is it that
fiction exists why do we need Heroes
villains why do our stories require
conflicts for our characters to overcome
to be interesting this is something that
all the Creations in the show have to
come to terms with in their own way
would guts from berserk be able to
accept what's happened knowing his
perseverance inspired thousands to push
through their own struggles would Olga
from kurino react well knowing that she
helped
never mind I love stories I love stories
so much I found a career talking about
how much I love stories and when I saw
this series exploring the importance of
fiction in our lives I didn't just
appreciate the very original way it went
about it but I also appreciated just how
personal it felt to me and then the show
ended on a four episode Balls to the
world action free throw and I was happy
again recreaters is a fan fiction for
anyone who's ever created something a
celebration of anime and the culture
behind it a look into the dangers of
online toxicity a boatload of fun and a
love letter to stories themselves can it
be a little messy yeah yeah is the
dialogue a little bloated yeah is the
pacing a bit off yeah but now I've just
come to Value something that so
specifically speaks to my tastes even if
the execution isn't perfect a seven or
eight out of 10 show that appeals to me
is in my opinion more important than a
perfectly crafted 10 out of 10 classic
that doesn't and that's why I'll always
choose something like Tales of her eyes
over the last of us Scott Pilgrim Over
The Godfather hell is why I'm so
addicted to Genji even though I know I
could clown on this game for [ __ ]
days a show like this was never going to
be super popular or go down as a
critically acclaimed classic but it's a
series brimming with so many interesting
ideas so many original Concepts so many
fun moments that never failed to put a
smile on my face and a core that speaks
to my love of fiction there is no other
anime like recreators nothing else I can
recommend to you this was a batshit
crazy idea for a show and somehow
someone was equally batshit crazy enough
to approve it give me a choice of a
popular highly acclaimed anime like Jiu
Jitsu kaisen or recreators and I choose
recreaters every time we've seen
variations of the show before they were
called bleach or you Hakusho and no I'm
not calling them the same show but you
know what I mean [ __ ] just look at the
beginning of Chainsaw man right now and
tell me the premise and plot structure
isn't almost identical there's gonna be
more Jujutsu kaisins in the future
there's going to be more my hero
academias in the future there's gonna be
more Narutos in the future but there's
only ever been one recreaters
look at that
[Music]